self checkout machines could be a thing
of the past big box retailers like
Walmart and others are removing the
devices at some of their stores mostly
because of theft but also because
customers hate the darn things the
barcodes never work and scanning fruit
as Jesse just told me is a nightmare
judge you have some experience with this
uh you seem to like I don't like it we
were talking inak scanning fruit scan no
but just this whole these whole these
machines you know what I like to use the
machines because I because I'm faster
than they are but here's the thing right
there's always
yeah I am yeah yourself do okay here's
the thing here's the thing the problem
is when you go there they just throw
everything on top of everything so you
have a tomato they throw a can on the
Tomato I'd rather pack my own bag but
the problem is with these self checkouts
is that that a lot of people don't know
how to use them and it takes forever and
so the companies would rather you you do
it yourself because they don't want to
hire people it's cheap is this going to
affect employment numbers and workers I
don't care I just care how it affects me
Harold I get in and I see a self
checkout line that's open and I see a
line long around the the back that I'm
going into that long line it's too much
pressure I get there I have enough
pressure I get there I'm trying to like
I'm trying to find the barcode where is
the barcode Harold it's not in the same
place and then all the time I put the
thing down and it doesn't count it and
then I put it down and then it double
counts it de de someone has to come over
then they're looking at everything I'm
buying
and then by that time that other line is
already through sounds like that word
you use
sabot what are your thoughts about this
well I do think that it might be going
away for a minute but I think Innovation
is going to make this a lot better for
everybody but it's going to mean fewer
employees are going to be needed because
there's a store for example at New York
airport I was just saying and I think
Amazon has a few of these stores too
around like in Seattle you scan your
credit card as you walk in and then you
put whatever ever you want in your own
bag pack it however you want and then as
you're leaving your credit card gets
charged with whatever is in the bag how
they do it call it magic call it
intrusive whatever it is but I think
technology is going to solve a lot of
this and the thing is the self-checkout
machine it might not work all the time
but it definitely doesn't need health
insurance and it's not going to call in
sick and so we have to be thinking about
what is going to happen with AI has a
lot of promise but I think there's a lot
of things happening to workers and it's
going to happen quickly because this
stuff is coming fast especially if you
have a lot of thievery things like that
right the theft stuff is big for them
but as you take Gus out to go shop what
it wear this I love it by the way
Jesse's version of uh self checkout is a
mirror I love self checkout I feel
useful when I'm doing it it's like a
video game that you're part of you're
ding ding ding I like looking up the
fruit and the vegetables that's so much
but the most important thing is I am in
control of the bagging and as a veteran
of Albertson's supermarkets I know
bagging so well you build a foundation
with the sturdy heavy products then on
top you put the you put the lighter
items and and and it that's how it works
they don't do that anymore and no one
double bags anymore unless they're
dating Joy bayar oh because she eats a
lot of food Jessie she eats a lot of
food so I I like control over the
bagging I like accomplishing something
small it makes me feel good and I I just
hate waiting in line behind people that
are always looking for the club card I
have a CL you know remember in the old
days when you would go there with your
mom and the person in front of you the
writing a check they would write the
check they would write they wouldn't
write the check right away they' like oh
it's time to pay now can I get cash back
in my big bag and find my checkbook and
then I'm going to write it out and who
do I write it out to and it was so
annoying remember you could get cash
back can I get add an extra $10 I used
to do that for my neighbor Marge oh I
loved Marge and also I could buy her
cigarettes for her she had some fat kind
of cigarettes they would send me with a
note Benson and hedges oh she bought
cigarettes for her friend Marge no
wonder you're 5all I was I was hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else